-Ice, welcome back to the show.
And thank you for coming on.
We love it when you come by,
bud.
-You know, it's always a treat
when players meet, man.
It's always a treat
-Ah, I love it.
[ Laughter ]
I've got to just say,
I'm fanboying out a little bit
here for you,
'cause I saw you at the Grammys,
on the --
This is the 50 --
50th anniversary of hip hop.
The tribute to hip hop.
And you came out and crushed it,
buddy.
You were unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was all thanks to Questlove.
-It's all thanks to Questlove.
-All thanks to Questlove.
I was minding my business,
I get a phone call.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mind my business.
I got a phone call.
Quest says, "Man, I need you
at the Grammys on Sunday."
I'm like, "I can't do it."
Because I'm --
We film every weekday.
So, Mondays, I work.
So, I can't go
to the Super Bowl,
I can't go to Grammys.
And he was like,
"Ice, this is gonna be epic.
This is not something
you want to miss."
And for a quick second, I said,
"I don't want to be the guy
sitting at home watching it
and saying,
'You know,
they asked me to do this,'
and everybody saying,
'You lying,'" you know?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And then I also knew
Quest probably had Ice Cube
on speed dial, right?
So --
[ Laughter ]
Soon as I --
So I was like, "Man, yeah."
So, I called "Law & Order,"
and they said,
"Well, you know,
you have that episode off."
We take two episodes off
every season,
and it was just a natural.
And I went out there,
and it was with all my peers.
And it was really one of
the greatest moments on stage.
It was only eight bars,
but it was eight bars
to probably the most people
I've ever performed to live
in my life.
-Yeah, you nailed it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was flawless.
-Mm-hmm.
-Were you nervous at all?
-Yes.
Yeah, I was nervous.
Because, you know,
they running a track.
And the track is coming in,
and you gotta catch your cue.
And, you know,
Black Thought'll tell you,
"You miss that cue,
the show keeps going."
So, I'm waiting,
and Scarface is rapping, right?
And there's this intro
to "New Jack Hustler" --
[ Beatboxing ]
But with everything going on,
everybody's having fun,
but I'm listening.
You never --
I was listening so hard.
And when I heard that, I just
had to come in, "Hustler!"
And I was like, "I'm on beat!"
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But if you missed that cue,
it was a wrap,
and it was gonna be very,
very, very disrespectful.
It was gonna look real bad.
-You crushed it.
Couldn't have been
more flawless.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
-And I was, like, so happy and
so psyched to see you do that.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Then, right on the heels
of performing at the Grammys,
you got your star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-How 'bout that?
-I got a couple photos here.
Here's you with
your beautiful wife, Coco,
and your beautiful daughter,
Chanel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What --
What does it feel like?
Was it -- talk to me.
What is it like?
-Hey, man, as many times
as I got arrested
on Hollywood Boulevard
and saw those stars like this...
[ Laughter ]
-That's the only way you saw
the stars up close, huh?
-I was like, really --
But you know what?
My friends were more excited
about it than me.
You know, they --
It started to weigh on me
as it came --
got closer and closer.
They said,
"No, do this for your kids.
Do this for everybody
that loves you."
Then when I -- I went there,
South Central showed up.
They said, "You brought a star
back to the hood, Ice."
So it became bigger and bigger.
And then, of course, Dick Wolf
was there, Mariska was there.
But it was really --
It's a star for music.
So, for the first time,
my "Law & Order" family
was surrounded
by my music family.
-Wow.
-So, Chuck D came,
Ice Cube came, Russell came.
It was dope.
-Wow, that's so cool.
That's well-deserved.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well-deserved.
You changed the game, bud.
Speaking of the game,
let's talk about your podcast,
"Ice-T's Daily Game," okay?
-Yeah.
-This is --
I think this is perfect for you.
-Well, for the white people out
there, Black people call --
Black people call
any type of wisdom "game,"
'cause we figure this is the
game of life, you understand?
So, when I say I'm the "daily
game," it's the game of life.
So, people say,
"What game are you playing?"
I'm like, "I've been playing it
since I was born.
This is the game of life."
[ Laughter ]
-This is life.
-You dig?
So, when I got on Twitter,
I was like, you know,
Twitter is mob mentality.
Whoever has the most mob --
that's -- it runs Twitter.
So, I said, "I gotta do
something to get people
to come back to my page
every day,
so I gotta do something daily."
-Yeah.
-And I came up with
"The Daily Game."
So, it's quotes,
it's inspirational quotes.
And it was going so good
on Twitter,
IHeartRadio came at me and said,
"Let's do a podcast where people
can listen to it every day."
It's a little bit of knowledge,
it's a little bit of wisdom,
and it's real quick.
They're like
five-minute podcasts.
-Like,
can I give a couple quotes?
Just see what you think of them?
-Why not?
I'll break them down for y'all.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
"If you're a giver,
learn your limits,
because takers don't have any."
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Ooh. See?
Felt that game go up in you.
It was like --
-Yeah.
Got a little game.
We got a little game here.
-And, also, we call 'em --
in the hood, we call 'em jewels.
-Oh, yeah.
-Because it's something
valuable.
Hold on to that.
"I'mma hold on to that."
So, that was the jewel.
Drop another jewel right now.
-Yeah, here you go.
[ Laughter ]
"Your character will outweigh
any lie told about you.
Those who know you, know you."
[ Audience "Yeahs" ]
[ Applause ]
-I mean, how many times
have you heard somebody come out
and try to tell a lie?
You say, "Nah, nah, nah, nah.
They didn't do that.
I need more facts."
You know, so --
you know, character.
Okay, keep going.
-Yeah, yeah, I like that.
[ Laughter ]
"I am -- I'm only responsible
for what I say,
not for what you understand."
[ Audience "Yeahs" ]
[ Applause ]
That's -- That's a jewel.
-You got to --
You got to get the podcast.
It's all over.
It's on Spotify.
-You know what I'm saying?
-Tune in to this.
Every day, you gonna get
a little bit of something
that you can -- and I'm quoting
everybody -- Aristotle --
I even quoted you.
-I heard this, by the way.
It was today you quoted me,
and I --
Honestly, it meant the world
to me, you know,
'cause I'm a big fan of you,
obviously.
Mm-hmm.
-But I said a quote --
I guess I said a quote,
"Have fun. Be silly.
You're allowed to be silly.
There's nothing wrong with it."
-"Nothing wrong with it."
You know?
And people say,
"Well, Ice, you came up,
you with the gangsters."
Let me tell you, man.
They tell -- They laugh,
they joke, they tell --
We have more fun in the hood...
-Make fun of each other.
-...just laughing,
making fun, bagging.
You know, shooting the dozens
at each other.
So -- And, also,
one thing about having fun,
you gotta have fun.
Those moments when you're really
having fun, really enjoy them.
Don't feel guilty for them,
'cause pain is coming.
Pain is guaranteed.
That's not a joke.
Think about it.
Think about it,
how often you're dealing
with hardships and things,
and those few moments,
when you're really happy
and laughing, enjoy them.
Don't feel guilty for them
'cause they'll --
Those are rare, all right?
Understand that.
-Yeah, enjoy it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love that.
"Ice-T's Daily Game," IHeart and
wherever you listen to podcasts.
I want to talk about
"Law & Order."
But I also want to bring up
your good friend,
Richard Belzer,
who recently passed away.
-Well --
Just what I just said, okay?
So, I have one of
the greatest weeks of my life.
I go out, have fun at the
Grammys, I get this star.
Everybody's like, "Ice, Ice,
this is your week."
Wake up the next day,
Belzer passed away.
-Geez.
-See what I'm saying?
-Yeah.
-So, those moments when I was
having fun, that was --
that was just a short blip.
And now I gotta deal with
the death
of one of my
really close friends.
I mean, when I came on "SVU,"
me and Belzer,
we clicked really quickly.
And it's like --
It's hard to talk about Belzer
without being funny,
but Belzer was like --
-He was one of
the funniest people on Earth.
-Belzer got me real quick.
He says, "Ice-T,
you're gonna be my partner.
You know what I look for
in a script?"
I'm like, "What?"
He goes, "Days off."
[ Laughter ]
-That's funny.
-He said, "We're both
nightclub entertainers.
We both don't like working late,
and we don't like working much.
Me and you'll
be great partners."
I said, "Well, Belzer,
you're Jewish, and I'm Black,
so if -- so if the Klan come,
I just gotta outrun you."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on, bud.
Belzer, you will be missed.
-I love Belzer, man.
-Well, "Law & Order: SVU"
has reached another --
a new milestone.
You've done over 500 episodes.
It's the longest-running
drama series on TV.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
Does it sink in?
Do you just go, "No, this is
just -- it's just happening"?
-The residuals sink in.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I mean --
No, I mean, it's cool.
I mean, I just got on the show
to do four episodes,
and it just keeps on going.
And this year, we had one of the
greatest ratings seasons ever.
So, we haven't been picked up
for the 25th season,
but you got Dick Wolf.
I mean, Dick Wolf
has six shows on NBC.
-Yeah, he's great.
Thank you, Dick Wolf.
-We're sitting pretty,
we're sitting pretty.
So, we'll be back
for season 25, 26...
I'mma stay on
until the wheels fall off.
Black people
don't jump off boats,
especially when
they're still floating.
You understand?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's the next
"Daily Game."
-That's the next "Daily Game."
-We ain't leaving.
-Can we set up this clip?
I think it'd be best
to set this up
'cause it's very --
it's kind of interesting.
-Well, in the episode, I --
I spoke on my partner
to my new partner, Kevin.
And I was speaking to him,
and I spoke on --
I didn't say Belzer's name.
-Right.
-I didn't say Munch's name,
but it was a reference to him.
The show came on, and three days
later, he passed away.
-Here's Ice-T
in "Law & Order: SVU."
Take a look at this.
-You're not fooling anybody.
I see your armor.
-Oh, humor, Fin.
-See, I had a partner,
years ago,
an old homicide detective.
He had the same exact
defense mechanism.
-He still around?
-Ah, he retired.
Guess he just ran out of gas.
Last I heard,
he moved back to Baltimore.
Met a divorced female rabbi.
-A rabbi?
-Yeah.
Yeah, and he bought back
his old cop bar.
-[ Chuckles ]
-It's about 1:30 a.m.
He's probably cracking a joke
to some barfly.
That skinny bastard
had a punch line
for every second of the day.
-Yeah.
Come on, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah.
-Ice-T, everybody.
"Law & Order: SVU"
airs Thursdays.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thursdays at 9:00 p.m., on NBC.
More "Tonight Show" after
the break. Stick around.